COMMITTEE TO ORDER- AND WITH A
HAPPY NEW YEAR MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES
MINING MINING HERE RAFI WILL
ROTH HERE WELL PRESIDENT WILL
CARE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
AND IT JUST FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE I KNOW
THAT- SENATOR BATES IS
PRESENTING A BILL AND WILL BE
HERE- AS SOON AS SHE CAN. BUT
LET ME GO AHEAD AND START AND
SEE IF I CAN GET A CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
INCLUDE. ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. I ITEM
NUMBER THREE REFERENCE OF BILLS
ITEM NUMBER FOR A JOB THE
SESSION SCHEDULE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY. N. ITEMS NUMBER FIVE
THROUGH EIGHT WHICH ARE FLOOR A
KNOWLEDGE MINTS REQUEST SO.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
OUR MAN SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS BATES
MONNING. MONNING I RAFI RAFI I
WILL WILK AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR SENATOR BATES WHEN SHE
ARRIVES THANK YOU AND OUT WITH
THAT LET ME GO AHEAD AND INVITE
THE FIRST ARE. PERSON APPOINTEE
UP ARANEA ORTEGA DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES WELCOME. AND I WOULD
ASK IF YOU WOULD- GO AHEAD AND
MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS IF
YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE ANYONE
THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU HERE
TODAY THAT YOU WANT T POINT
OUT- AND THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT
INTO- COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME THIS ONE YES THERE YOU
GO THANK YOU. THANK YOU YES I
WOULD LIKE TO. YES I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY HUSBAND MIKE
MENDOZA AND MY DAUGHTER GRACE
MENDOZA WHO ARE HERE WITH ME
TODAY. ALWAYS HERE IN SUPPORT
AND- THANK YOU FOR. ALLOWING ME
TO DO TO ASK YOU GET CLASS
CREDIT TO BE HERE I THINK WE
OUGHT TO WORK ON THAT. YOU GOT
SOME EDUCATION FOLKS IN THE
ROOM I SEE MAYBE THEY CAN WORK
ON THAT FOR YOU. WELCOME. THANK
YOU A CHAIR ATKINS AND
SENATORS- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO APPEAR TODAY I
WANTED TO START BY THINKING
I'LL GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR
APPOINTING ME- AND ALLOWING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES KELLY CHARTS
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT- I ALSO-
WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK- THE STAFF AT KELLY CHAR
SOME OF WHOM ARE HERE TODAY
WITH ME AND- OTHERS WHO ARE
WATCHING BACK AT THE OFFICE-
WITHOUT. THEIR SUPPORT BOTH FOR
ME AND FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
OR IN THE TRANSITION I WOULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY TO HAVE ANY OUR
SUCCESSES TO REPORT TO YOU. I
STARTED THE POSITION IN MARCH
OF TWENTY NINETEEN- HAVING HAD
A BIT OF TIME TO REFLECT ON ON
THE TIME AND PHYSICIAN IT'S-
IT'S VERY HELPFUL FOR ME TO
HAVE BEEN AND BE ABLE TO TALK
TO FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE- WHEN
I STARTED. THERE WERE- MANY
THINGS TO JUMP RIGHT INTO WE
HAD- SIX CONTRACTS EXPIRING IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND ONE THAT
WAS EXPIRED FROM A PREVIOUS
YEAR- THERE WAS ALSO EIGHTY.
MOST OF THE CHIEF NEGOTIATORS
THAT WE HAVE A COUCH ARE WERE
VACANT AT THAT TIME SO THOSE
ARE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES WHO
SERVE AS THE CHIEF NEGOTIATOR-
AT THE BARGAINING TABLES AND WE
HAD TO FILL ALL THOSE POSITIONS
SO WE JUMPED RIGHT IN. OF
FILLING THOSE POSITIONS AND-
GETTING THE CONTRACT.
DISCUSSIONS GOING AND- HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT BY THE END OF
TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAD SEVEN
CONTRACTS- INCLUDING THE SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND CONTRACT THE
COVERS NINE BARGAINING UNITS
AND SO- YOU SAW MANY OF THOSE.
OUT LAST YEAR TO RATIFY BEFORE
YOU ADJOURN AND- WE CONCLUDED
ONE AT THE VERY END OF THE YEAR
IN TWENTY NINETEEN SO MISSING
THAT ONE SHORTLY- THE WORK IS
CERTAINLY NOT DONE WE HAVE
SEVEN MORE TO NEGOTIATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY SO THAT IS A- BIG
PART OF WHAT GOES ON IN CALLIE
CHAR. AN ARM CRTAINLY OF A ONE
OF THE MOST KIND OF ENERGIZING
PARTS OF THE JOB IS FOLLOWING
UP ON THOSE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS- ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT I. THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO HIGHLIGHT IS. IN
SEPTEMBER GOVERNOR NEW SOME
CONVENIENCE- A GROUP OF
AGENCIES FOR TERRY'S THE
UNDERSECRETARIES THE DIRECTORS
OF EACH OF THE DEPARTMENT. OF
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR. FOR
A- FIRST OF ITS KIND FORUM ON-
DISCUSSING THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITY FOR CREATING A MORE
INCLUSIVE. A DIVERSE RESPECTFUL
AN EQUITABLE WORKPLACE FOR
STATE EMPLOYEES. AND I WAS
HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
EFFORT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATES THE AGENCY AND THE
STATE. BOARD OF AN AND ALL OF
OUR STAFF ACCOUNT ARE WE MADE
.COM I THINK A VERY MEANINGFUL
IT AND FOR THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED AND FROM THAT
DISCUSSION- SEVERAL PAST. IS
WERE CREATED- ON DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION PAY EQUITY ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRADING
IN RESPONSE AND ALSO A OF
PUBLIC SAFETY COMPONENT WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT DIVERSITY. AND
HIRING EFFORTS JUST IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY CLASSIFICATION.
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
EXPECTED TO PRESENT TO THE
GOVERNOR IN JULY- IT'S AN
EFFORT THAT. INCLUDING THE TASK
FORCE MEMBERS OF THE SUBGROUP
BIRDS THERE DOZENS OF STATE
LEADERS WORKING ON THESE ISSUES
AND I'M I'M VERY EXCITED BY THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED SO FAR AND I THINK
IT'S A REAL- OPPORTUNITYTO
MAKE. A DIFFERENCE IN SOME
AREAS THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR STATE SERVICE FOR
DECADES REALLY. SO WITH THAT I
WILL- AND MY REMARKS AND I'LL
TAKE ANY COPY TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU I'M I THINK I MIGHT LEAD
OFF WITH ONE QUESTION GIVEN.
WHAT THE RULES COMMITTEE IS HAD
TO. WORK ON THESE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS- GALLO HR PROCURED-
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY IT
SYSTEM TO TRACK SEXUAL
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
COMPLAINTS JUDGEMENTS
SETTLEMENTS- WITH THE DATABASE
EXPECTED TO BE UP AND RUNNING
THIS MONTH. I WOULD ASK WHAT
THE CURRENT STATUS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW IT SYSTEM.
TO TRACK SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINTS
JUDGEMENTS SETTLEMENTS- IF YOU
COULD JUST KIND OF OPEN WITH
THAT AND DO YOU EXPECT CAL HR
TO UTILIZE THE DATA. COLLECTED
BY THE NEW TRACK. EXPECT THAT
TO HAPPEN SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO- YES STARTING
UNDER- THE GOVERNOR BROWN'S-
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT WOULD TRACK THESE- THE
CASES FILED TO- IO OFFICERS
WITHIN STATE DEPARTMENTS. OF
THAT SYSTEM WAS- PLANT FUNDED
IN PLANS PRIOR TO MY ARRIVAL AT
KELLY CHAR BUT I'M I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT IT WENT LIVE ON A
JANUARY ONE. SO BEGINNING WITH
ANY- CASES THAT ARE FILED-
WITHIN A DEPARTMENT EIGHT
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT-
ANY KIND OF COMPLAINT. THAT
FALLS INTO THE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY CATEGORY OF A- CUP.
FOR PROTECTED CLASS ANY OF
THOSE TYPES OF COMPLAINTS WILL
BE ENTERED INTO THE SYSTEM OF
THE SYSTEM FOLLOWS THAT
COMPLAINT FOR THE LIFE OF THE
COMPLAINT THE- THE ACCESS TO
THE SYSTEM IS VERY LIMITED
WITHIN A DEPARTMENT SO
DEPARTMENTS EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY OFFICER. THEIR
INVESTIGATOR AND THOSE APPS
MANAGERS ARE THE ONLY THING YOU
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM
THE- INFORMATION ABOUT. WHEN
THE INVESTIGATION BEGINS WHEN
THE INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETED
WHETHER THE SUB THE- COMPLAINT
TO SUBSTANTIATED OR NOT IF IT
IS SUBSTANTIATED IT'LL TRACK
THE ULTIMATE DISPOSITION OF THE
CASES- IF THERE ARE. LEGAL
ACTION. ON THAT RESULT IN
SETTLEMENTS IT WILL TRACK THAT
INFORMATION ALTHOUGH WE WOULD
ASSUME THAT THAT WOULD BE-
SOMETIME THE FUTURE THAT WE
WOULD SEE THAT TYPE OF THE
NATION BECAUSE THAT THE CASE IS
BEING FILED OUR CASES FILED
JANUARY ONE OR LATER. SO IT IS
A LOT WE HAVE A I KNOW. SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS HAVE ACCESS IT
SINCE JANUARY ONE. AND JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION BEFORE I TURN
OVER. OUR THERE'S A NEW
LEGISLATION TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
EXPAND- SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING TO NOT JUST MANAGERS
AND SUPERVISORS BUT TO ALL
EMPLOYEES. CAN YOU GIVE ME A
SENSE OF HOW THAT. HOW THAT'S
GO AND WHAT'S CAL HR'S ROLE. IN
THAT. OR SO- THE- THE ORIGINAL
BILL REQUIRED THAT THAT
TRAINING BE DONE BY THE END OF
TWENTY NINETEEN GOVERNOR SOME
DID SIGN A BILL TO PUSH THAT
DEADLINE OUT UNTIL THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. WE DO KNOW THAT-
MANY DEPARTMENTS WERE ALREADY
TRACK TO HAVE THEIR EMPLOYEES
TRAINED THE END OF. NINETEEN SO
I KNOW THAT MANY OF THE HAVE
ALREADY DONE TRAINING ALSO
THERE WERE- THEY WERE
DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE ALREADY
TRAINING ALL EMPLOYEES AND NOT
JUST THE SUPERVISORS- CALLIE
CHARS ROLE IN THAT IS MORE IN A
OF MONITORING AND- OVERSIGHT
ROLE WE- WE DO OFFER THE
TRAINING CLASSES. IN AS PART OF
OUR MANAGEMENT TRAINING AND
THAT IT AS PART OUR TRAINING
PROGRAM OVER ALL THOSE CLASSES
ARE AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE TO
ENROLL IN. I WOULD SAY
TYPICALLY DEPARTMENTS TAKE THE
LEAD ON TRAINING FOR ONLY
PLEASE AND NOT CAN HANDLE IN
ANY. WAYS THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO TRY TO MAKE SURE.
THIS TRAIN- THING TO MENTION IS
GOVERNOR KNEW SOME VERY CLEAR
AT THAT FORUM EVENT WITH ALL OF
THE DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP AND
IN OTHER COMMUNICATIONS.
EXPECTATION HIS. THING
PARTMINER ACCOUNT FOR MAKE SURE
THAT. SHE WILL COME ANSWER THIS
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND SO
WHAT THE SUBGROUPS OF THE TASK
FORCE THAT I MENTIONED IS
LOOKING AT COMPLIANCE TOOLS
WHAT ARE SOME THINGS WE COULD
DO TO HELP DEPARTMENTS A TRACK.
COMPLIANCE SOME OF THE LARGE
DEPARTMENTS- HAVE. LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS WHERE
THEY'RE BETTER ABLE TO AUTOMATE
TRACKING BUT I KNOW OFFERED FOR
CALLIE CHAR WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES WE'RE
TRACKING NOT ON AN EXCEL
SPREADSHEET. SPREADSHEET AND
SO. ON THERE ARE TOOLS OUT
THERE THAT DO A REMINDERS AND
KIND OF HAVE. MORE OF A
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO MAKING
SURE THOSE DEADLINES ARE BAD
AND WHEN PEOPLE CYCLE IN
TRAINING COMES UP THAT THEY ARE
AGAIN BEING TRAINED ON CYCLE.
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE EXPECT
TO BRING FORWARD IN JULY. THANK
YOU. I SENATOR ROTH CANISTER IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS THANK YOU
AMEND PRO TEM. CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ON THIS
JOB. HAS TO BE AN
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT JOB
GIVEN THE. OF SCOPE AND BREADTH
OF EMPLOYMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES THAT- THERE WE HAVE
WORKING DILIGENTLY FOR THE
STATE. JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS
ONE. YOU KNOW IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR OVER THE YEARS THE
THERE'S BEEN A TUG BETWEEN-
MANAGEMENT AND H. R. AS TO WHO
ACTUALLY IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
AS MOST IMPORTANT FUNCTION IN
IN THE OPERATION OF THE
BUSINESS AND WHO ACTUALLY- HAS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ROLE IN
DISAPPOINTING TERMINATION AND
PROCESSING OF COMPLAINTS IN.
THE HUMAN RESOURCES
PROFESSIONALS OVER THE YEARS
HAVE FOUGHT TO RETAIN HIS SEAT
AT THE TABLE IN FACT HAVE A
VERY IMPORTANT SEAT AT THE
TABLE AND I THINK LARGELY BY
AND LARGE THEY'VE WON THAT
BATTLE AND H. R. PROFESSIONALS
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR PLAY AN
INTEGRAL ROLE IN INITIAL
DECISION MAKING ON EVALUATION
OF COMPLAINTS IN. THIS ONE IN
THE NATION THE CIVIC. IN THIS
STATE IN A SERIES OF NEWS
ARTICLES I KNOW YOU'VE PROBABLY
NOTED THEM. HAVING TO DO WITH
THE ALLEGATIONS OF
DISCRIMINATION- IN PROMOTION
PRACTICES IN ACTIONS WITHIN.
DEPARTMENTS THE HANDLING OR
IGNORING OF THE EEO COMPLAINTS-
THE DENIAL OF ACCOMMODATION
REQUESTS FOR THOSE WITH.
DISABILITIES AND MY QUESTION IS
THIS I MEAN I UNDERSTAND THE
EFFORTS ON IT. THE EFFORTS ON
COMPLAINT TRACKING. BUT HOW DO
WE STRENGTHEN THE COMMAND IN
QUALITY CONTROL FUNCTION- OVER
HR DECISION MAKING. AN AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS OF CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT VIS A VIS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
BETTER FOR QUESTION IS IT'S A
DIFFICULT QUESTION BUT IT'S
FAIR LET ME LET ME. BECAUSE
WHAT I'VE SEEN AND OBSERVED IS
WE HAVE LOWER LEVEL OF
EMPLOYEES WHO OFTENTIMES OR
THE- OR THE SCREENING DEVICE
FOR AEO COMPLAINTS WE HAVE
SUPERVISORS WHO PERHAPS. MAYBE
THEY'VE BEEN TRAINED BUT MAYBE
NOT ENOUGH WHO ARE MAKING
DECISIONS ON ISSUES THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL OF
LIABILITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU CAN TRACK
THOSE THINGS BUT YOUR PEOPLE
ARE NOT IN THE DECISION MAKING
EQUATION AND SO THERE'S NO WAY
TO PREVENT OR MITIGATE THE
LIABILITY THAT'S WHERE I'M
GETTING. TO WITH MY QUESTION.
SO I THINK A ONE THING THAT
MAKES THAT DIFFICULT IN THE
STATE STRUCTURE IS THAT
CALIFORNIE H. R. PROFESSIONALS
FOR EACH DEPARTMENT EACH
DEPARTMENT IS DELEGATED THE
AUTHORITY TO DO ERROR OF HIRING
AND- PERSONAL TRANSACTIONS A
LOT OF WHAT'S WHAT YOU WOULD
CALL THE HR IS. OCCURRING IN
THE DEPARTMENTS CAPTION OURS
ROLE IS ON THE SITE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- KELLY CHAR IS
VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN ENFORCING
THE RULES THERE ARE A LOT OF A
RULES AND STRUCTURES WITHIN
CITY SERVICES YOU WILL KNOW- WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
STATE PERSONNEL BOARD ON- THE
COMPLEX FUNCTIONS THEY HAVE A
COMPLIANCE REVIEW UNIT THAT.
VIEWS OF WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE AT HEARING TO
THE STATE'S POLICIES- AND THEN.
SAID THAT THEY ARE NOT WILL BE
ALONG WITH THE STATE PERSONAL
BOARD WILL WORK TO INTERVENE
INCLUDING THOSE DELEGATIONS CAN
BE. TAKEN OKAY SO AND WE HAVE
WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF THAT SO
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES WHERE YOU
MIGHT HAVE SEEN IN THE
NEWSPAPER RESULTS OF THOSE
ISSUES IS THERE DELEGATION IS
REMOVED AND WAS- HIRING
DECISIONS AND THINGS THAT. WERE
NOT. BEING PROPERLY THEN. MADE
THOSE DECISIONS MADE BY. AFTER
THE TICKET ESTHER FEE. THAT
THAT IS SO LET ME JUST- SO DID
THE HR PROFESSIONALS IN AGENTS
OR DEPARTMENTS WORK FOR YOU
KNOW THEY REPORT TO THE AGENCY
HAD OR A SUPERVISOR UNDERNEATH
THE AGENCY HAS SO THAT'S THE
DICHOTOMY IN THE ISSUE THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
DOTTED LINE RESPONSIBILITY IS A
FOUR AS OPPOSED TO SELL IN LINE
SUPERVISION. AND RESPONSIBILITY
HAS BEEN ADDED DISCUSSION OF
SHIFTING THE WAY HR
PROFESSIONALS CERTAINLY THE HR
MANAGERS IN AN AGENCY. THEY
WERE DISCUSSION HAVING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS REPORT DIRECTLY TO
CAL HR AND TAKE THEM OUT FROM
UNDER THE DIRECT SUPERVISION OF
AGENCY HEADS AND SUPERVISORS
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE OF
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES TO THE
STATE SUCH AS EMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
I THINK AS IT RELATES TO MOST
HR FUNCTIONS THAT WOULD BE VERY
HARD TO IMPLEMENT BECAUSE OF
THE SIZE AND THE COMPLEXITY OF-
THE OPERATIONS OF THOSE STATE
DEPARTMENT SO AS I THINK ABOUT
WHAT MY JOB IS AND THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT OUR FOLKS HAVE I
THINK IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
HARD FOR ME TO IMAGINE TAKING
OVER. ALL OF THE HIRING FOR A
DIP IN THE COUNTER AT THE
LARGE. HAVE THEIR OWN. LAW
PERSONAL SHOPPER WELL I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT WHAT I'M
SUGGESTING IS THERE A WAY FOR
AN HR PROFESSIONAL EMBEDDED IN
THE- TICKET AGENCY CALTRANS. TO
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY TO YOU. OR
TO YOUR SUBORDINATES IF THERE'S
AN ISSUE OR SITUATION GOING ON
IN A PROTECTED WAY SO THAT WE
KNOW AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
INSIDE THE H. R. HIERARCHY IT'S
SOMETHING IS AMISS. IN CALTRANS
OR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES OR
PICK AN AGENCY SO I DO THINK
THAT THIS DISCRIMINATION
COMPLAINT TRACKING SYSTEM AND
POLICY THAT IS NEW FOR TWENTY
TWENTY GETS A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE THE DOTTED LINE
QUESTION THAT YOU MENTION- WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN ROLLING OUT THE
SYSTEM AND IN- DOING THE
TRAINING ON WHO'S ALLOWED TO
ACCESS THE SYSTEM AND WHAT
INFORMATION HAS TO BE ENTERED
INTO THE SYSTEM. WE HAVE
UNCOVERED A THREE IS WHERE-
DEPARTMENTS- PERHAPS DID NOT
HAVE THAT- EEO OFFICER
REPORTING DIRECTLY TO THE
DIRECTOR AS THEIR REQUIRED TO
EITHER IN THERE OR GET FOR
CHART OR IN IN PRACTICE THE
ISSUES WERE BEING RATE FRANKLY
TO THE DIRECTOR. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SYSTEM
ALLOWED US TO- ADDRESS THOSE
ANOMALIES AND ALSO THEIR
ABILITY TO ENTER AND THE CASE
IS THE TYPES OF COMPLAINTS AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
COMPLAINT IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM. THERE. WHICH
MEANT THEY GO AND THEY HELLO
THE DESTINATION REPORT AND THE
WHAT THE- ULTIMATE OUTCOME IS
OF THAT CASE. IT DOES GIVE
CALLIE CHAR I THINK MORE WINDOW
INTO THOSE TYPES OF ISSUES ON
WHAT ARE HAPPENING AT THE
DEPARTMENT LEVEL THAN BEFORE
AND THAT WAS THE INTENTION WAS
TO RAISE THE LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT. OVER DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS- I DO
AT THIS MOMENT I DON'T THINK
WE'VE CONTEMPLATED TAKING THAT
BEYOND HE EEO COMPLAINTS BUT
IT MAY BE A MODEL FOR HOW WE
WOULD HAVE MORE OVERSIGHT OVER
OTHER TYPES OF ISSUES THAT- PUT
THE DEPARTMENTS AT RISK. WELL
NOT TO BELABOR THIS BUT I WOULD
ASK YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
TO. THINK ABOUT WHETHER WE
COULD FURTHER PROFESSIONAL LIFE
THE H. R. CADRE AND STATE
GOVERNMENT- CREATING A
SITUATION WHERE WE DON'T REMOVE
THE- THE- THE CONTRIBUTION IN
THE WORKS OF THE HR
PROFESSIONAL DOES INSIDE OF AN
AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT WE DON'T
TAKE THE- HR. PROFESSIONAL
OUTSIDE OF THE SUPERVISION OF
THE AGENCY SECRETARY FOR
EXAMPLE BUT WE CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT AND A AND A FORMAL
PROCESS WHERE. BOTH THE
SECRETARY FOR EXAMPLE. AND CAL
H. R. AND THE HR PROFESSIONAL
KNOW THAT THE PROFESSIONAL CAN
GO DIRECTLY TO CAL HR WITH
ANYTHING OF ANY CONCERN OR IF
THERE IS A PROCESS IT. SEEMS
RIGHT. IN A VERY PROTECTIVE
CASE THAT WE HAVE SOME ABILITY
YOUR PROCEDURAL. BEFORE COME
CAN AFFECT REMOTE. THE HIGHER
IN HR THIRTY FROM A TICKET OR
THE OF A OR AN AGENCY INC AND-
GIVE IT TO YOU. THERE MAY BE A
WAY TO DO THAT I'M NOT SURE
THAT I'M SMART ENOUGH. ABOUT IT
BUT I KNOW OUR- CAN I. WORKING
ON THE- MATTER. TAKE WHAT
OTHERS ON THE NET QUESTION. TO
DO COMPANIES IN STUDIES. THAT
TENDS TO COME UP AROUND HERE
EVERY TIME WERE ASKED TO
APPROVE A ONE MO YOU OR
ANOTHER- WHAT ROLE DO YOU SEE.
AND WHAT UTILITY DO YOU SEE AN
COMPENSATION STUDIES AND IN OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
NEGOTIATION AND IN SETTING THE
PAY SCALES FOR OUR WORKERS WHO
WORK. DILIGENTLY FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT. THAT SAID A TIMELY
QUESTION AS WE HAVE JUST
RELEASED COMPENSATION STUDIES-
IN DECEMBER AND JANUARY FOR THE
NEXT- ROUNDS OF A BARGAINING
UNIT- CONTRACTS THAT ARE
EXPIRING AT AS I SEE IN MY
REVIEW OF THE CAN THIS MY FIRST
TIME FR GOING THROUGH
REVIEWING THE COMPENSATION
STUDIES IN ADVANCE OF
BARGAINING. I SEE THEM AS-
PROVIDING- THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE MARKET PLACE AND
GIVING US THE INFORMATION TO
ASSESS THE TYPES OF REQUESTS
THAT COME IN FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS AND FROM THE LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE SO WHEN WE ARE
PREPARING FOR BARGAINING WE'RE
HEARING FROM DEPARTMENTS ABOUT
EACH POSITIONS THEY'RE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME FILLING- WHERE
THEY'RE SEEING A LOT OF
TURNOVER- WE HAVE THAT BACK AND
FORTH WITH DEPARTMENTS AND WORK
THROUGH- OKAY IS IT. IS THE
SYSTEM A LONG TERM PROBLEM IT'S
A SHORT PROBLEM AND THEN WHEN
YOU LOOK AT HOW THAT. A GROUP
OF- JOBS COMPARES TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO THE LOCAL
AGENCIES YOU IT'S AT LEAST A
CHECK ON OKAY DOES IS THE
SOUNDING RIGHT IS THIS MAKING
SENSE THAT THIS IS AN AREA
WHERE WE NEED TO INVEST IN.
WHETHER IT'S A- YOU KNOW PAY
DIFFERENTIAL OF SOME SORT OR
JUST INCREASING COMPENSATION
FOR THAT PARTICULAR
CLASSIFICATION WE DID A LOT OF
THAT TYPE OF WORK IN THE LAST
ROUND OF CONTRACTS WHERE WE
HAVE. RESOURCES CHEN C. TWO
KILLER NUMER POSITIONS WITH THE
V. D. RATES WERE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRST. THE PAY HAD JUST REALLY
NOT KEPT UP WITH WHAT LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE PAYING FOR THOSE
EXACT OF JOBS AND- WE MADE
THOSE ADJUST. AND THAT IS VERY
MUCH BUT OUR. IT'S WHAT I'M
COMMITTED TO BEING AS PART OF A
THING AND WE'VE KIND OF THE
PROCESS AROUND THAT WHICH IS.
PROBLEMS ARE WE SOLVING AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE DEPARTMENTS TO
PROVIDE ITS DATA LABOR TO
PROVIDE A STATE A AND REALLY-
HELP THE DEPARTMENTS BE ABLE TO
FILL THE POSITION SO THAT THEY
CAN FOCUS ON THE PROGRAMMATIC
WORK. AND I THINK THE SALARIES
THE SALARY AND COMPENSATION
SURVEYS THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY PROVIDE US IS THAT BACK UP
DATA TO. TO COMPARE TO WHAT
WE'RE BEING REQUESTED WHO SETS
THE COMPARABLES IN THE
COMPENSATION STUDY. I'M I
BELIEVE WE DO I AM I'M IF I'M
WRONG I'LL GET BACK TO YOU ON A
CLARIFICATION BUT I BELIEVE WE
DO. THAT'S I'M JUST CURIOUS AND
YOU COULDN'T PROVE IT BY MAYES
SO THAT SOUNDS GOOD TO ME. WITH
RESPECT TO COMPENSATION STUDIES
THAN. WHICH SHOULD WE EVER BE
FACED WITH A. SOMETHING OTHER
THAN A COST OF LIVING INCREASE
IN A AND M. O. U. WITHOUT A
COMPENSATION STUDY TO BACK UP
THE INCREASE. I MEAN I THINK
THAT HAS HAPPENED BECAUSE THERE
HAVE BEEN DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT
METHODOLOGIES OR- WHETHER- PAST
STUDIES WERE. REALLY
REPRESENTING THE TYPE OF A
CLASSIFICATION IS I THINK THAT
THAT HAS HAPPENED. IN CASES
WHERE THE CLASSIFICATION IS
VERY UNIQUE TO STATE SERVICE
AND THERE REALLY- IT'S MUCH
HARDER TO FIND TRUE
COMPARABLES- I THINK THAT NOT.
NOT SPEAKING ABOUT THE PAST I
WOULD LIKE TO- HAVE A PROCESS
WHERE WE DON'T EVER ASK YOU TO
DO THAT WERE YOU ALWAYS HAVE
THAT DATA. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
I WOULD SAY THERE MIGHT BE
TIMES WHERE THERE ARE THERE ARE
OTHER DATA SETS THAT WE LOOK AT
AND THERE ARE OTHER
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR WHAT WE
BRING TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
RATIFY AND- THERE IS- WE WANT
TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE ABOUT WHAT THAT IS SO
IF IT ISN'T A SALARY SURVEY
THAT. RESULTED IN A PARTICULAR
A PAY INCREASE WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
REASONS WHY WE AGE DO WE REACH
THAT CONCLUSION. WELL I WANT TO
AGAIN SAY CONGRATULATIONS. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUALITY OF YOUR RESPONSES AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- CONTINUED
SERVICE. TO THE STATE YOUR
RECORD IS IMPECCABLE AND I
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
MAKING THE MOTION TO CONFIRM IN
VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM. SENATOR ROTH
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CONGRATULATIONS
LOOKING FORWARD TO- SUPPORTING
YOUR NOMINATION THIS YOUR IN
YOUR LAST POSITION AS I G. FOR
SUCH A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME SO
I WAS WONDERING WHY THE JOB AND
THEN AFTER HEARING THIS
CONVERSATION HOW SIMILAR IS
THE- THE IG POSITION WITH
CALTRANS TO DEALING WITH ALL
THESE OTHER AGENCIES IN ALL
THEIR- ACT HR ISSUES. TOM SO-
YES I WAS IN THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND MOST OF YOU WERE
HERE AND VERY KIND TO CONFIRM
YOU FOR THAT ROLE OF PREVIOUSLY
I THINK- YOU KNOW AS AS I
REFLECTED ON THIS OPPORTUNITY
COMING UP AND LEAVING THAT
POSITION EARLY IT WAS A TERM TO
POSITION AND I- I HAD TO.
DECIDE WHETHER THAT MADE SENSE-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT I
STRONGLY. POSITION AND FOCUSED.
THERE WAS REALLY ESTABLISHING
THE INDEPENDENCE OF TH OFFICE
AND HOW IT MIGHT OPERATE WITH
THE AGENCY SECRETARY THE
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR. BUT WHAT I
FELT STRONGLY WAS THAT THE-
THE- FOR THAT FONG THAT OUR
OFFICE TO FUNCTION WELL IS TO
HAVE A REALLY STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE FOLKS.
AND SENSE AT THAT POINT I HAD A
STRONG SENSE THAT THOSE WERE
GOING TO BE ALL NEW PEOPLE. IT
MADE SENSE THAT IT WOULD BE
GOOD FOR ME TO LEAVE A TIME TO
SELECT ALL OF THOSE NEW PEOPLE
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK. WHAT IT
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO ME TO
BE IN A LARGE DEPARTMENT EVEN
FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND
SEE THE- IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT COME UP
ABOUT THE LENGTH OF TIME IT
TAKES TO HIRE. PEOPLE OR- SOME
OF THAT PROCESSES. TO IS TO BE
IN A LARGE DEPARTMENT AND JUST
KIND OF SEE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT CAUSE THE TIME TO STRETCH
IT WAS VERY HELPFUL- I DON'T
THINK. I'D I NEVER I HAVEN'T
SEEN ANYTHING IN THAT
DEPARTMENT THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE I THINK
EVERYONE IS STRUGGLING WITH
TRYING TO ATTRACT THE BEST
CANDIDATES AND GET THE ONES
THAT ARE THE BEST IN AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT LOSING THEM
SOMEWHERE ELSE- A LOT OF. THE
STEAM IT WAS COMING UP IN MANY
CLASSIFICATIONS ACROSS MANY
DEPARTMENTS WHICH IS LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE PAYING MUCH MORE
THAN THE STATE FOR MANY OF OUR
JOBS- THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
I'D- I THINK EVERY STATE
DEPARTMENT IS FACING AN- AND-
THAT. MY EXPERIENCE THERE AS
WELL. THE SELECTION. YEAH A
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I ALSO WANT TO ADD MY
CONGRATULATIONS I APPRECIATED
THE TIME WE HAD TO REVIEW MANY
OF THESE ISSUES IN MY OFFICE
EARLIER TODAY I DO WANT TO
RETURN TO ONE OF THE AREAS THAT
THE PRO TEM ASKED ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY AROUND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
THERE WERE MEDIA REPORTS
INDICATING THAT AS MANY AS
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SUPERSTORE ILL.
NOW IN CALIFORNIA HAD NOT
RECEIVED THE TRAINING CAN YOU
GIVE US A PROGRESS REPORT ON
THAT AND WHAT STEPS ARE BEING
TAKEN. TO ASSURE THE PEOPLE IN
PARTICULARLY IN SUPERVISORIAL
POSITIONS I KNOW THAT WE ALSO
NOW REQUIRE ALL EMPLOYEES BUT-
FOR SUPERVISORS AGAIN TO
PROTECT AGAINST STATE
LIABILITY. THAT TRAINING SEEMS
IMPERATIVE SO I DO- THERE WERE
MEDIA REPORTS ABOUT- AUDITS
THAT HAD OCCURRED I THINK THAT
INFORMATION CAME OUT RIGHT
AROUND THE TIME THAT I WAS
COMING ON BOARD I'D I DO
BELIEVE THAT AND FOLLOW UP-
REVIEWS OF THE DATA- THE GAP
BETWEEN WHO HAD BEEN TRAINED
AND NOT TRAINED. WAS WAS
SMALLER THAN ORIGINALLY
REPORTED AND LARGELY HAD TO DO
WITH- HOW WHAT PEOPLE WERE
RESERVE REPORTING AS NON
COMPLIANCE- I KNOW SPEAKING
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN THE
DEPARTMENT. IF WE HAD EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE ON MEDICAL LEAVE FOR
FAMILY LEAVE ANYTHING LIKE THAT
IF THE TIME OF WHICH IS THE
WINNER OF THEIR TRAINING COMES
UP DURING THE TIME THAT SOMEONE
ASKS YOU. IS EVERYBODY TRAINED
YOU WOULD SHOW THEM IS NOT
TRAINED BUT THEY'RE NOT LIKELY
WORK IN YOUR OFFICE AT THAT
TIME AND THE EXPECTATION WOULD
BE AS SOON AS A RETURN TO WORK
THAT TO PRIORITY TO GET THEM.
BACK ON THEIR THINGS GOT. SO I
SAID THE- WORDS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAD NOT BEEN TRAINED AND THEN-
DID HOWEVER IT WAS STILL NOT AT
FULL COMPLIANCE AD I THINK
THAT- THAT WAS A LARGE PART OF.
A MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR WANTED
TO. THAT ALL. DEPARTMENT YOUR
SHIP THAT WAS HOW IMPORTANT IS
TO ACHIEVE THAT LEVEL COMPLY.
HOW CRITICAL IT TO THE- TO NOT
ONLY CREATE IN THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE WANT TO CREATE FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES AND PROTECTING THEM
BUT ALSO TO CREATING THE
ENVIRONMENT WE WANT SO THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO COME WORK HERE
SO THE NEW PEOPLE THINK OF US
AS THE EMPLOYER OF CHOICE AND
WANT TO BE WORK. STATES THAT
TOPIC IS LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
ISSUES ONE BEING HOW WE DELIVER
THE TRAINING ARE THERE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAYS TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS TRAINED-
THEY ARE LOOKING AT- COMPLIANCE
TOOLS AS WERE CALLING THEM AND
I THINK YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
WAYS IN WHICH THE
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINT
TRACKING SYSTEM WILL HELP US
IN- SEEING TRENDS IN HOW LONG
IT TAKES TO COME VESTED ASIAN
OR SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES
TOOLS LIKE THAT. ALSO THE FACT
THAT WE NEED TO GO DOWN THINGS
THAT THAT REMIND. EDITORS AND
SUPERVISORS THAT THERE THE
INSUBORDINATE MANAGING
SURPRISED HAVEN'T BEEN TRAINED-
YOU KNOW I THINK ABOUT IT IN
MOST DEPARTMENTS IF YOU YOU GET
THE AND YOU PROBABLY GET THIS
TO WE GET THE NOTICE THAT YOU
HAVE TO RESET YOUR PASSWORD
AFTER A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
AND WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WHEN
YOU'RE A NEW EMPLOYEE IF YOU
DON'T DO YOUR CYBERSECURITY
TRAINING YOU CAN'T CHANGE YOUR
PASSWORD TO BE AT THE A YOUR
PERMANENT PASSWORD AND SO.
THEY'RE CON KIND OF TICKLER
THAT YOU NEED TO GET THAT DONE
BUT THE TO MY KNOWLEDGE THERE
IS A SYSTEM THAT DOES THAT ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WELL ON THAT
MEETING. A GOOD TECHNIQUE YES
THAT BE EMPLOYED. AS HAVING THE
PASSWORD GO THROUGH THAT
CHECKLIST OF THE REQUIRED
TRAININGS. ROM NOT JUST THE SEX
HARASSMENT PREVENTION BUT OTHER
MEN'S IN ON THAT POINT. WHAT'S
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN YOUR
OFFICE STATE HR IN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS WHAT'S
YOUR OVERSIGHT OR ABILITY TO.
ENFORCE THAT COMPLIANCE SIR
REVIEW AND ENFORCE COMPLIANCE I
THINK- TO DATE TO THE
COMPLIANCE ON THAT PARTICULAR
TRAINING HASN'T REALLY COME
THROUGH THE AGENCY LEVEL RATHER
THAN THROUGH CALLIE CHAR. I
WOULD SAY THAT KELLY CHARTERS
ROLE IN IN THE OVERSIGHT OF
THAT- WOULD COME INTO PLAY TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WAS NOT- WAS NOT IN COMPLIANCE
OR SEEM TO HAVE SOME- REAL
BARRIER TO FOLLOWING THE STATE
POLICY THAT MAY PLAY INTO
HAVING THEIR DELEGATION REMOVED
IN WHICH CASE MAYBE WE WOULD
HAVE MORE OF A ROLE OF-
INSURING THAT TRAINING. BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE LIKE I
IS A DEPARTMENT RESPONDING TO
THE SECRETARY. SORT OF FOLLOW
HIS EVERYBODY BRIAN WELL IN HIS
CAN YOU MENTION THE- SENATE ON
AN EXPECTATION SO YOU'RE GOING
THAT IS WELL. I THINK AS PART
OF. CREATING THE CULTURE WE
WANT IT HAS TO BE NOT. A
SUBSIDIARY ISSUE THAT WE GET TO
BED BUT OF PARAMOUNT ONE ARM
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU WE DID
DISCUSS SOME OF THE OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUE SUCCESSION PAY
EQUITY DIVERSITY AND- I WAS-
ENCOURAGED BY BOTH YOUR
KNOWLEDGE XIN APPROACH TO THOSE
SO. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MADAM PO TEMP THANK YOU
SENATOR LET ME ASK NOW FOR-
MINT. YES ABSOLUTELY SENATOR.
JUST OF JUST A FOLLOW UP ON MY
ORIGINAL POINT HAVING TO DO
WITH CHAIN OF COMMAND AND
CONTROL AND QUALITY CONTROL.
JUST TO GET AN IDEA I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THE STATE IS STRUCTURED IN
THE HR. ARENA THESE DAYS BUT
HOW MANY SENIOR HR MANAGERS OR
DIRECTORS ARE THERE. FOLKS WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT HR FUNCTIONS IN
STATE GOVERNMENT. IS AT A
HUNDRED WELL AT I WOULD SAY. I
THINK EVERY DEPARTMENT OF-
CONSEQUENTIAL SIZE SO THERE ARE
A FEW DEPARTMENTS AND BOARDS
THE OUTER THE HAVE VERY VERY
TINY STAFF AND THEY MAYBE HAVE
THEIR AGENCY HELPING THEM WITH
HR BUT ANY DEPARTMENT OF SIZE
WOULD HAVE AN HR DIRECTOR- I
THINK THAT'S PRETTY CALMLY
FIELD POSITION ON THAT PERSON
MAY OR MAY NOT BE REPORTING TO
A KIND OF AN ADMIN CHIEF- WHO
WOULD ALSO HAVE A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL ROLE IN H. R.
ISSUES AND THEN UNDERNEATH THE-
HR DIRECTOR THERE WOULD LIKELY
BE- PEOPLE AT THE SENIOR
MANAGEMENT LEVEL WHO HAVE. A
DIFFERENT KIND OF CATEGORY OF
AREAS THEY MIGHT RESPOND FOR
THE E. MIGHT BE ONE. HIRING
MIGHT BE ANOTHER PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT ANOTHER SO I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER WE CAN
CERTAINLY GET YOU MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NUMBERS
BUT- I THINK. IN ORDER FOR A
STATE SERVICE TO FUNCTION THE
WAY IT FUNCTIONS TODAY WITH THE
LAYERS OF COMPLEXITY THE CIVIL
SERVICE RULES- EACH DEPARTMENT
REALLY HAS A PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL
HR FUNCTION. INTERNALLY MY
CONCERN MY CONCERN IS
STANDARDIZED QUALITY. AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT THEIR WIDE
VARIATIONS OF QUALITY EVEN
AMONG THE LARGER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY AND SOMEHOW. WE HAVE
TO ENGAGE IN AN EARLIER POINT
THAN WE ARE CURRENTLY AIMING
TOWARD WHICH IS TRACKING AND
CATCHING THE STUFF AT THE
BACKEND WE NEED TO ENGAGE AT
THE FRONT END WE NEED TO GET A
BETTER DEAL ON STANDARD. SURE
QUALITY AND CAN- IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND I DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
THE ANSWER FOR THAT BUT- JUST
TO REITERATE MY EARLIER POINT A
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THAT TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET A HANDLE- AND WITH CAL HR
IS THE BIG HR DEPARTMENT HAVING
SOME CONTROL OVER WHAT H. R.
PROFESSIONALS ARE DOING DOWN IN
THE BELLS OF THESE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE I'M- I FEAR
THAT. WE DON'T KNOW. AND WE
DON'T KNOW UNTIL WE GET A
COMPLAINT. OR WORSE A PIECE OF
CIVIL LITIGATION WHERE WE FIND
OUT WHETHER IT'S GOOD OR IT'S
BAD. AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU EGGMAN. THANK YOU I
THINK WHAT I WANTED TO- IS GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT BUT RECOGNIZE THAT US
SENATOR BATES HAS JOINED IS NOT
ASK HER PUT HER ON THE SPOT
RIGHT NOW SHE WILL HAVE THOMAS
SHE WANTS TO RE DIRECT AND ASK
A QUESTION OR COMMENT IF THAT'S
OKAY. SO SHE CAN. GET AROUND.
SO WITH THAT LET ME I ASK THOSE
WHO WANT TO COME FORWARD AND
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. GIVE ME YOUR
NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT AND THE-
VERY SHORT WHAT YOU THINK.
EIGHTY PARRIS OF SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND REPRESENTING STATE
EMPLOYEES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NEGOTIATIONS ARE
NOT ALL. NEGOTIATIONS
NEGOTIATIONS ARE NOT EASY- BUT
I THINK LIKE WE SAW HERE TODAY
THE THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS- YOU
WILL GET THOUGHTFUL ANSWERS
FROM THIS ORTEGA SO WE ARE HERE
TO SUPPORT HER ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT. JUNE MADAM- PRO TEM AND
MEMBERS TO TOP AND I AM MADE TO
FOR TODAY- THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERVISORS
STRONGLY URGE YOUR CONFIRMATION
FOR DIRECTOR ORTEGA- BOTH PAGAN
AT ASSESS OR- OUT OF OUR-
PRODUCTIVE AND POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH CALLIE CHART
THAT HAS CONTINUED. UNDER THE
DIRECTOR AND HER TEAM AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER FOR YEARS TO COME THANK.
THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRMAN. MY NAME IS
KERRI LEE AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN AND I'M HERE
TODAY WITH OUR PRESIDENT
RECKLESS PASSKEY WERE BOTH HERE
IN PERSON BECAUSE IT IS OUR
PLEASURE TO SUPPORT DIRECTOR OR
TAKE OUT FOR HER CONFIRMATION-
WE TO MAKE OF IT WE ARE IN
NEGOTIATIONS. WITH ME WITH
KELLY CHAR THIS YEAR. REALLY
FELT VERY COMFORTABLE THAT
THEIR CONCERNS WE EXPRESSED
WERE HEARD. THAT THERE WAS A
LOT OF CREATIVITY IN ADDRESSING
THOSE CONCERNS AND IT'S OUR
PLEASURE TO RECOMMEND HER TODAY.
Q. WELCOME MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT RAN WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF THIS ORTEGA- WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK SHE'S DONE
IN THE PAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
WE CAN LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HER. IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SURE MEMBERS I'M
ELIZABETH HAS BEEN SO I'M HERE
IN A PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY
TODAY I AM A REGISTERED
LOBBYIST IN SACRAMENTO. ADRIN
AND I ARE AT THE ARC OF HER
pPROFESSIONAL CAREER STARTED
ABOUT THE SAME TIME IN THE-
LATE NINETEEN NINETIES AND I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE TO WORK- I'M
GONNA TRY NOT TO CRY. BUT IN.
AS PROFESSIONAL COLLEAGUES BUT
SUBSEQUENTLY AS- THE- CO
WORKERS AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE HAVE
A TWENTY YEAR FRIENDSHIP. AND I
WILL JUST SAY THIS HEARING HAS
AN ABSOLUTE. UNCANNY ABILITY TO
LOOK AT A VERY COMPLEX PROBLEM-
AND IDENTIFY AND UNDERSTAND A
PATH IN A WAY TO GET THERE AND
THAT WILL SURFACE. STATE VERY
VERY WELL. AND I'M VERY PLEASED
TO SUPPORT HER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT. ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING
NONE OUT LET ME RETURN AND ASK
SENATOR BATES IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU I JUST HAD A REALLY QUICK
WHAT AN IDEA OF MY STAFF SAID
IT HADN'T BEEN ASKED YET ABOUT
THE AUDIT THAT SENATOR MORE
LOCK INTRODUCED- AND IT'S IN
THE STAGES OF IMPLEMENTATION I
UNDERSTAND JUST GIVE ME A- A
QUICK LITTLE THUMBNAIL ON THAT
AND ALLIED WORKERS COMPENSATION
ABILITY TO SAVE MONEY AND- I
THINK THE- HONOR TO. PUT FOR
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS YES THANK
YOU CENTER BASE FOR THE
QUESTION YES THE AUDITOR PUT
FORWARD SOME RECOMMENDATIONS-
DIP SUGGESTING A COUCH ARE
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENTS WHO
WERE NOT- USING STATE FUND FOR
THEIR WORKERS COMPENSATION-
PROVIDER TO. GIVE THEM SOME
ASSISTANCE WITH DATA THAT WOULD
SHOW MAYBE SOME SAVINGS THAT
THEY CAN ACHIEVE IF THEY DID
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION AND SO
WE HAVE I BELIEVE I SIGNED THE
LETTER TO THE AUDITOR LETTING
HER KNOW THAT WE WOULD BEGIN-
IMPLEMENTING THAT STATE FUNDED
GREAT TO WORK WITH US ON- DOING
THIS CALCULATIONS AND THEN WE
CAN PROVIDE THEM TO THE
DEPARTMENTS. THANK YOU ON
SENATOR MORE LIKE AN IRISH-
I'LL ARE DISTRICTS TOUCH ONE
ANOTHER SO WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SAY. THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON IT FOR THAT'S GREAT
THANK YOU YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT
AND I AM NOT. I DO APOLOGIZE
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY DO ONE ON ONE I
ALWAYS ENJOY THAT. THANK YOU
CONGRATULATIONS AND YOU DO HAVE
MY SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ASK FOR A MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR MADAM
SECRETARY SENATORS BATES AYE
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH. ROTH I WILL WILK AYE AT
CAN I. THANK YOU IT IS
UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU ALL. SO ON AS WE SHIFT
GEARS LET ME GO BACK- CENTER
BATES ARE YOU OKAY IF WE OPEN
THE ROLE AND OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY ON ON THE ITEMS-
BEFORE US CALL THE ROLL. ITEMS
TWO THROUGH EIGHT SENATOR BATES
RIGHT BATES AYE THAT'S FIVE
ZERO THANK YOU THAT'S
UNANIMOUS- SO THOSE ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PASSED THANK YOU MEMBERS.
YES. THE SO LET ME GO AHEAD AND
CALL OUR SECOND COME FREE HERE
UP LAW LIKE TIVO SIMONE MEMBER
TRUSTEES OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WELCOME HAS
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN IN THE
MORNING THEY HAVE. AND I'LL
WAIT ON THE DOOR CLOSED SO THAT
WE CAN GIVE YOU OUR FULL
ATTENTION. OKAY THANK YOU AND
TO SAY WELCOME AND- YOU HAVE
BEEN HERE BEFORE. PUTTING
COMMENTS RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE WHO IS HERE AND THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND I WILL
TRY TO BE EXTREMELY SHORT I'M
WITH MY OPENING REMARKS I'M SO
HONORED TO BE IN FRONT OF YOU
ALL TODAY- FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS THE FIRST- HAVING
SERVED FOR JUST ABOUT THREE AND
A HALF YEARS. ON THE CALIFORNIA.
ON THIS BOARD- HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE GREAT HONORS OF MY LIFE-
FOR MANY REASONS AND THE MAIN
ONE BEING- I'M A MOTHER AND THE
CHILDREN WHO MY CHILDREN WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE TODAY ONE
YOU SAW AT THE LAST
CONFIRMATION HEARING SHE WAS
JUST ABOUT DONE WITH HER TIME
AT UC DAVIS AND THIS WEEK SHE
HAS LAW SCHOOL INTERVIEWS AND
SO AS A SINGLE MOTHER WHO'S
RAISED HER I'M SO PROUD. MY
EIGHT YEAR OLD. IS DELIVERING
HER I HAVE A DREAM SPEECH TODAY
IT IS MORE OF THE KING'S
BIRTHDAY SO THEY BOTH COULD BE
HERE. WITH ME TODAY BUT I CAN'T
READ- SO MUCH OF WHAT WE'VE
GONE THROUGH BTH AS A SINGLE
AND WIDOWED MOTHER. AND MOVING
MY CHILDREN TO EDUCATION. THE
SECOND REASON WHY I'M HONORED
TO BE HERE. IS BECAUSE FOR THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS. WHO ATTEND
THE CSU- I'D DEEPLY DEEPLY
BELIEVE THAT THEY DESERVE A
CONSISTENT UNBRIDLED VOICE X.
SPECIALLY. FROM SOMEONE LIKE
MYSELF WHO TO BE TWELVE YEARS
TO MOVE THROUGH UNDERGRADUATE
EDUCATION. EDUCATION IS NOT
ONLY A PRIVILEGE AS YOU WELL
KNOW IT'S A HUMAN RIGHT AND
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A
SIGNIFICANT AN AMAZING JOB AT
PROVIDING ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY AND I KNOW THAT WE
CAN DO MORE SO MY- WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE IN THE- GOVERNOR
HIMSELF KNOWS THAT THROUGHOUT
MY TWENTY PLUS YEARS OF
ACTIVISM AND ORGANIZING IN THE
STATE ON BEHALF OF LOW INCOME
CHILDREN. I FEEL LIKE I'M JUST
GETTING STARTED IN PUBLIC
SERVICE TO ME NOT ONLY AS AN
HONOR. IT'S MY OBLIGATION AND
SO I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND I'M- WILLING AND READY AND
ANXIOUS TO HEAR YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- LET ME START WITH SENATOR
MINING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND WELCOME CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUED SERVICE NOT JUST
IN THIS ROLE BUT IS I'VE
LEARNED ON MANY OTHER FRANCIS
WELL IN. CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
TREMENDOUS ACHIEVEMENTS OF YOUR
CHILDREN THE SHARED WITH US.
THEY'RE LUCKY TO HAVE YOU. MY
QUESTION WE HAD A NICE
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY I WAS
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR OVERALL
KNOWLEDGE IN. SOME OF YOUR
SENSE OF PRIORITIES FOR C.
ISSUE FOR STUDENTS FOR STAFF
FACULTY- I KNOW YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A REFINED
POSITION ON THIS BUT I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US TO HEAR
SOME OF THE- PROS AND COS.
LOOKING AT THIS PROPOSAL I
UNDERSTAND TO ADD A FOURTH.
YEAR HIGH SCHOOL REQUIREMENT
FOR STUDENTS THAT WANT TO BE
ADMITTED TO SEE ISSUE. IN
SCIENCE FOR ANALYTICAL STUDIES.
HOW ARE YOU APPROACHING THAT
CLEARLY THE GOAL IS TO HAVE.
MORE HIGHLY PREPARED STUDENTS
COMING IN TO SEE ISSUE BUT IS
THERE ANY DANGER OF STUDENTS
BEING DENIED ACCESS BECAUSE OF
LACK OF ACCESS TO THOSE PROGRAM
SIR LACK OF APPROPRIATE
COUNSELING FOR ANY NUMBER OF
REASONS. SENATOR I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND ALSO THE
ANNOUNCES THAT YOU BROUGHT
WITHIN THE QUESTION I'M CLEARLY
THERE- THE QUEUE OUR PROPOSAL
IS ONE THAT. I HAVE NO DOUBT IN
MY MIND THAT THE SENIOR MEMBERS
OF OUR STAFF THE CHANCELLOR
MEMBERS OF OUR BOARD. WHO HAVE
EXPRESSED- THE NEED TO MOVE
THIS PROPOSAL OF LONG. ARE ALL
IN THE SAME THINKING THAT THE
STUDENTS THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
EVEN RESUMING STUDENTS WHO ARE
COMING INTO OUR UNIVERSITY-
SHOULD. HAVE ALL THAT THEY NEED
TO NOT ONLY PREPARE FOR A-
CAREER IN STEM BUT REALLY TO
CONFRONT THE SHIFTING
TECHNOLOGICAL. INFRASTRUCTURE
OF NOT ONLY OUR STATE BUT OUR
COUNTRY. THE CHANCELLOR HIS
SENIOR STAFF I'VE MET WITH THEM
NUMEROUS TIMES I'VE HAD FORTY
TWO CONVERSATIONS WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. I THINK ALL OF US FOR
FOLKS ARE PROPOSING. THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE PROPOSAL
THE FOLKS THAT ARE ASKING US TO
HOLD UP WE'RE ALL CLEAR THAT
STUDENTS IN THE STATE DESERVE
EVERYTHING AND I THINK I SAID
TO YOU I WOULD LOVE FOR US TO
BE LIKE OUR NORWEGIAN
COUNTERPARTS. ARE WE THERE YET
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. AND
SO I'M CONFLICTED I HAVE TWO
WEEKS BEFORE I DELIVER THIS
VOTE- AT THAT DíAS. AND WHAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE MERITS IN
THE VALUE. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
HOW WE MIGHT MOVE FORWARD
SHOULD THE PROPOSAL MOVE
FORWARD IN THE SEVEN YEARS.
WILL BE ONE. WEATHER IS THE
LEGISLATURE. WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIFTH
GRADERS RIGHT NOW. WILL WE BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE OFFERINGS. NOT JUST IN OUR
URBAN CENTERS. BUT IN OUR RULE
CENTERS AS WELL OF. SO THAT'S
ONE. AND IF MOVING FORWARD. NOT
ONLY THE FISCAL IMPACT AS A
QUESTION- BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
WHAT MANY OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
HAVE SAID IS. ACCESS QUESTION
IS IN BUT WE I WILL NEED TO
CONTINUE TO UNDERSTAND. THE
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS THE
DISPARITY ANALYSIS THAT I KNOW
THAT A NUMBER OF COMMITTEE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE CONDUCTED SO.
MY THOUGHTS ARE- WITHIN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS AGAIN WITH
THE MEETINGS WITH THE
CONVERSATIONS READING BOTH THE
PROS AND CONS IS TO COME TO
SOME CONCLUSION. ABOUT
RESOURCES HOW WE MIGHT GET FAIR
AND REALLY TO FOR MYSELF TO BE
ABLE TO. HONESTLY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION WILL WE BY MOVING
FORWARD TONIGHT ACCESS TO YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO ENTER OUR
INSTITUTION I WISH I COULD SAY
SENATORS THAT TODAY I WAS YES
OR NO. BUT I GUARANTEE YOU. THE
MORNING THAT I GO AND I INNER
THAT VOTE- I WILL HAVE GOTTEN
THE INFORMATION THAT I NEED TO
BE ABLE TO. PROFOUNDLY AND
SECURELY FEEL THAT I HAVE MADE
THE VOTE THAT RESTS NOT ONLY ON
MY CONSCIENCE BUT THE
CONSCIOUSNESS OF THE PARENTS
THAT I BELIEVE THAT I
REPRESENT. AND THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT A AND I
APPRECIATE THAT NISHINO FROM MY
QUESTION. IN NO WAY DID I SEEK
TO PUSH YOU FOR HOW YOU WOULD
VOTE I KNOW THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE-
INSTILLED GREAT CONFIDENCE IN
APPROACH AND UNDERSTANDING. THE
DIFFERENT VIEWS THAT ARE BEING
VOICED SO I WISH YOU THE BEST
IN REACHING THAT DECISION AND
I'M CONFIDENT WHATEVER IT IS
IT'LL BE WELL INFORMED AND- AS
I HOPE WILL ALSO BE WITH THEIR-
COLLEAGUES ON THE BOARD. SO
THANK YOU AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS THANKS FOR YOUR
SERVICE MADAM PRO TEM I DON'T
HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS THANKS
TO HER THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU- MAN
PROTIUM AND CONGRADULATIONS ON
ASSIGNMENT I AM VERY IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR PASSION AND YOUR
ENTHUSIASM YEAR A- YEAR ARE
GONNA BE GREAT ON THE BOARD
KNOW THAT YOU'RE ALREADY
INVOLVED THAT TIME. THAT YOU
ARE VERY VERY COMMITTED DATE
SHE SAID IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS. I THE CITY CLEAN
CONCERNED AS YOU SHOULD BE
SERVICES AND. IT WAS LATE OF. A
AN AUDIT OF THE OVER THE
UNIVERSITY YES SAN MARCOS SIDE
TOUCHES MY DISTRICT. I AM VERY
VERY CONCERNED OUT WHAT
APPEARED TO BE VERY LAVISH
EXPENSES THEY HAVE RATHER
EXPENSIVE TASTES THAT'S RIGHT
TALK ABOUT RESOURCES. THAT WE
WANT TO SEE GOING TO OUR OUR
STUDENTS AND THE- EDUCATIONAL.
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY NEED THIS
WAS PRETTY SHOCKING THAT'LL
GIVE ME SOME THOUGHTS ON- YOUR
APPROACH TO THIS ABSOLUTELY AND
HAVE STANDARDS SO. WHERE YOU
KNOW THE HOTELS THAT YOU CAN
SELECT ARE NOT FIVE STAR PLUS
DIAMOND RESORTS ON. THAT
FEDERAL SO I SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS ON THAT. YOU KNOW YOU
YOU AND I ACTUALLY AGREE AS I A
YOUNG PERSON I WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THEAGE
OF NINETEEN AND HAD TWENTY
EMPLOYEES I HAD NOT FINISHED
COLLEGE- BUT ONE THING THAT I
KNEW. IS THAT THE PUBLIC TRUST
AND WORKING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO DESERVED EVERYTHING THAT
EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE SPEND NOT
ONLY NEEDED TO BE ACCOUNTED FOR
BUT WE HAD TO MAKE REAL SERIOUS
DECISIONS OF HOW WE SPEND THOSE
MONIES. I TO APPALLED. APPALLED
I READ ALL OF THE ARTICLES I
SAW ALL THE CHARGES. AND HERE'S
WHAT I'M. I'M PLEASED WITH WE
HAVE A NEW PRESIDENT. FOR SAN
MARCOS SAN MARCOS AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT SHE SAID ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- I FEEL
EXTREMELY CONFIDENT SPEAKING
WITH OUR CHANCELLOR- IN OUR
AUDITING STAFF THEY HAVE
CLAMPED DOWN. IN ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS REALLY
ENCOURAGING- AND I BELIEVE THE
PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW HOW ARE
SENIOR STAFF ARE SPENDING THEIR
RESOURCES. IS THAT WHAT. WHEN
YOU BUST OPEN THE WHOLE CHANGE
AND NEW STANDARDS COME THROUGH-
OUR NEW PRESIDENT IS AS A DEEP
DEEP CONVICTION. THAT BECAUSE
THE PUBLIC TRUST WAS LOST THAT.
THE ROLE MOVING FORWARD IS TO
GAIN IT BACK UP I THINK THAT
THE MEMBERS OF THE CSU BOARD
WORK TO APPALLED. BECAUSE EVERY
TIME THAT WE ARE SPENDING IS
ABOUT NOT ONLY THE FUTURE BUT
THE NOW FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. I AM COMPLETE
AGREEMENT WITH YOU THAT FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY ACTUALLY BEEN
PROVED AND- THINKING TWICE
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE EXPENSE IS
HOW ALL PUBLIC FUNDS SHOULD BE
SPENT SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR-
CONCERN AND I AND I SHARE IT. I
JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP BUT WHEN
DO YOU THINK BEYOND IT WILL BE
COMPLETED THE AND WILL YOU BE.
PREPARED TO PROVIDE US WITH
THOUGHT WHAT THE NEW STANDARDS
WOULD BE IT SEEMS TO ME THERE
NEEDS TO BE CAP. ON WHAT IS ON
ELIGIBLE EXPENDITURE IN UP TO
WHAT AMOUNT I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION NOT FOR
THE PUBLIC AND CERTAINLY FOR US
AS DECISION MAKERS. I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT DATE OF THE
COMPLETION OF THE AUDIT. AND I
DON'T WANT TO MISS SPEAK BUT
WHAT I KNOW WE'RE WE DO HAVE
CSU STAFF IN THE ROOM. AND WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
COMMITTEE AND YOUR OFFICE
SPECIFICALLY A BOTH HOPEFULLY
IMMEDIATELY THE DATE- AND OF
COURSE THE FINDINGS FROM ABOUT
IT. THANK YOU AND I AM VERY
HIGH ON YOUR APPOINTMENT AND
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR RE
APPOINTMENT SO I'M I WOULD BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE PAROCHIAL YES
MY PRIVATE IF. STATE OF SOUTH
DAKOTA. EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS. THEY
HAVE SEVEN FOUR YEAR PUBLIC
COLLEGES. AND UNIVERSITIES
ARABS AND NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE ZERO. SO I
DON'T THINK YEARS IT CODE
SHOULD BE AN IMPEDIMENT TO YOUR
ABILITY TO ACCESS HIGHER
EDUCATION SO- TWO PRONGED
QUESTION ONE ARE YOU GUYS
LOOKING AT DOING MORE REGIONAL
EDUCATIONAL CENTERS BECAUSE I
HAVE ONE AREA OF FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE AND THEY
HAVE NOTHING. SO WE MAKE
INVESTMENT ALL THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE THEN THEY LEAVE AND THEY
NEVER COME BACK. AND THEN TO
ARE WE WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
GUARANTEE SEATS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS THAT GRADUATE FROM MY
THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. OPEN
ENDED SO. I LOVE THE QUESTION
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT ACCESS- AND
YOUNG PEOPLE AND RESUME HIS
IPAD RESUMES BECAUSE I WAS
RESUMING STUDENT I TOOK A TON
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSES I
CAME IN NOT DOING SO WELL IN
HIGH SCHOOL WAS IN AND OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL HAD A REALLY
TROUBLED PAST- WHICH ENLIGHTEN
ME AND BRINGS ME TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. I DID COMMITTEE
COLLEGE FOR THREE YEARS AND
WHEN I FINALLY TRANSFER TO A
FOUR UNIVERSITY ONLY ONE OF
THOSE CLASSES COUNTED. SO
ACCESS TO ME AND CLARITY IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BUT
PARTICULARLY TO YOUR QUESTION-
LAST YEAR IN THE LAST BUDGET
CYCLE THIS LEGISLATURE IN THIS
GOVERNOR. PUT FORTH RESOURCES
FOR CONSULTANT TO THINK ABOUT
THE EXPANSION OF THE CSU-
PARTICULARLY THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- LOOKING STOCKTON. AS
ONE PARTICULAR POTENTIAL-
POSSIBILITY I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IN THE
STATE THIS BIG BUT THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE AND RESUME RISEN. FOLKS
INTERESTED IN PURSUING THEIR
COLLEGE. ARE A EVEN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION HAVE DIRECT
ACCESS- AND I'M HOPING HAT
MOVING FORWARD THAT REPORT THAT
ANALYSIS JUST AS THE SIT ON A
SHELF BUT THE WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE. IN THE TRUSTEES A
LIKE MAKE A REAL COMMITMENT. TO
FOLKS EXPECT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- BUT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE DIRECT ACCESS NOW WILL WE
HAVE IT IN OUR LIFETIME. THAT'S
THE QUESTION AND I WOULD LOVE
TO CONTINUE TO BE IN
CONVERSATION WITH YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE AS I KNOW MEMBERS- BOTH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING THE
ACTUALLY WON SAID TODAY TALK
ABOUT EXPANSION TALK ABOUT
EXPANSION- I THINK IT'S A IT'S
A QUESTION OF RESOURCES AND
PRIORITY AND THAT PRIORITY
NEEDS TO BE MAKING THE- FIRST.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THERE THAT CHILDREN OF
MIGRANT FAMILIES THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO ACCESS THIS
AMAZING INSTITUTION THAT WE
CALL THE CSU I WOULD LOVE.
CONTINUING CONVERSATION BUT
RIGHT NOW. HAVE A CONSULTANT
THEY'RE MOVING FOR. MY HOPE TO
SEE THAT REPORT EXTREMELY SOON
AND I KNOW THAT STAFF WOULD
DELIVER IT TO YOUR OFFICE AND-
MORE BACK AND FORTH BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT. I'M NOT UNDER
ANY ALLUVIAL OF FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T REPRESENT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I KNOW I KNOW- BUT- I'M
NOT UNDER ANY ILLUSION GETTING
TO SEE ISSUE CAMPUS ANYTIME
SOON BUT THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO
DELIVER- EDUCATION AND AGAIN I
JUST IT'S JUST A TRAVESTY TO ME
THAT. WE AKE ALL THIS
INVESTMENT IN THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE TO LEAVE
THEN IT THEY NEVER COME BACK
AND IT'S HEART BREAKING IN. AND
THE REASON FOR THAT I BELIEVE.
SO CHICKEN THEY WRITE BUT IT'S
HAVING THOSE EDUCATIONAL HIGHER
EDUCATION RESOURCES THERE SO. I
LOOK FOR TO WORKING ON THAT
THANK YOU. RACHEL IT IS MUCH.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS. WE WILL. FIND YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SENATE ROTH. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM- CONGRATULATIONS
MEMPHIS THE THANK YOU SIR LUCKY
TO HAVE YOU. OF LET ME JUST.
TAG ON TO MY COLLEAGUES CENTER
MUNNINGS QUESTION ON THE.
QUANTITATIVE REASONING PROPOSAL
I RECOGNIZE I DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE RESEARCH THAT YOU ALL DO
AND CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE THAT.
I WORK FOR THE BOARD TO DO BUT
I HAVE TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN
ABOUT THE- WANTED TO THE
RESEARCH REASONING RATHER
PROPOSAL THAT'S COMING BEFORE
YOU. AND WONDER IF WE'RE SIMPLY
ADOPTING A SYSTEM- THIS ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
HIGHER EDUCATION WHEN IN SOME
AREAS WERE GOING IN THE
ABSOLUTE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
YOU'LL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
AND THOSE WHO. WAY THROUGH THE
RESEARCH MAKE AN APPROPRIATE
DECISION BUT AT SOME POINT AND
LIKE TO HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND YOUR
BOARD MEMBERS ARE ON THAT
SUBJECT. RESPECT TO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
VICE CHAIR. I ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATED IN THOSE BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE STUDY
FOR NEW CAMPUSES. AND I
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR ACCESS
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE AREAS OF
OUR STATE WHICH DO NOT HAVE SI
ISSUE CAMPUSES BUT- I WONDER
WHY. I DID NOT HEAR AT THE TIME
AND HAVE NOT HEARD ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT BRANCH
CAMPUSES. OF A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
ESTABLISH A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OF THE PROBLEM WITH
DOING SO OF COURSE IS SOMEWHAT
ALIGNED WITH INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE BUDGET SO YOU NEED A
PRESIDENT YOU NEED AN EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT YOU NEED FIVE
VICE PRESIDENTS. DEANS AND ALL
OF THE REST WHICH WE HAVE AT
OUR EXISTING CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES AND WE
WOULD NOT NECESSARILY NEED IF
WE ESTABLISHED A BRANCH CAMPUS
WITH A BRANCH CAMPUSES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WERE IN CENTER
WORKS TO. SOME OTHER LOCATION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
CLASSROOMS AND INSTRUCTORS YET
WITH A BRANCH CAMPUS SHE WOULD
HAVE ACCESS CLASSROOMS AND
INSTRUCTORS AND THE ABILITY TO
MOVE FORWARD- AND ACHIEVE YOUR
HIGHER EDUCATION OBJECTIVES SO
I'M HOPING THAT- IN YOUR
CONTINUED SERVICE ON PC ISSUE
BOARD. MAYBE YOU COULD- IF THAT
DISCUSSION IS NOT OCCURRING YOU
COULD YOU WOULD CONSIDER
INITIATING THAT CONVERSATION.
TO SEE WHAT WE WOULD NEED TO DO
IS A STATE LEGISLATURE- TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN BOTH FOR MY
COLLEAGUES IN THEIR
CONSTITUENTS IN AREAS OF THE
STATE THAT SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TODAY. WHAT WHAT IS. I'D
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT. BECAUSE
WHAT I THINK WE ARE BOTH SAYING
AND SOME ERROR HOW I'M HEARING
IT. WE DO HAVE EXTENSIONS BUT
ARE THEY SIMPLY IN PLACES WHERE
CITIES AND REGIONS WHERE
THEY'RE ALREADY A BIG- BRICK
AND MORTAR CAMPUS. AND I THINK
WHAT WE CAN DO A STAFF IS
IMMEDIATELY GET- THIS FULL
RULES RULES COMMITTEE- NOT ONLY
OUR MAP BUT OUR LIST OF
EXTENSION- INSTITUTIONS. BUT
WHERE THERE ARE NONE WHAT
HAPPENS IS- OUR YOUNG PEOPLE OR
RESUME OURS THEY LEAVE. AND
THEY DON'T COME BACK. OR THEY
JUST DON'T GO AN ONLINE
EDUCATION WHILE THE SALE THE
CSU PROVIDES IT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH AND SO- I THINK
WE CAN ONE GET YOU WHAT WHAT IS
NOW AND- OF THE TRUSTEE.
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A FEW YEARS
FOR YOU TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
PHYSICALLY ON YOUR DESK I'VE
BEEN ON THE CSU FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS NOW AND I KNOW STAFF- I
KNOW THE RHYTHM OF HOW THINGS
WORK AND INSTEAD OF JUST BEING
ON THE BOARD IT WAS TELLING
STAFF EARLIER IT'S TIME TO
REALLY DO SOMETHING I REALLY
WANT TO BE AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THIS BODY THE NOT ONLY MOVE THE
ACCESS CONVERSATION TO THE
DIVERSITY CONVERSATION- AND SO
I LOOK FOR TO BE IN
COMMUNICATION WITH YOU AND WITH
YOUR COLLEAGUES. BUT IN THE
NEAR TERM LET'S GET YOU THE
REPORT OF WHAT'S CURRENTLY
EXIST THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION IN FOR THE BUY IT IN
OTHER WORDS IT'S CHEAPER TO
CITE A BRANCH THAN IT IS TO
BUILD A CAMP THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT. AND MY FINAL
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH-
ACADEMIC COUNSELING I. HAVING
VISITED THE. ONE OR MORE CSU
CAMPUSES- BEING INVITED TO
PARTICIPATE WAS SO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WERE. CONDUCTING
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS OVER
THE BREAK I. HAVE BECOME
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ACADEMIC
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIO. ON
RC ISSUE AND ACTUALLY ARE UC
CAMPUSES AS WELL. I GATHER THAT
THE RATIO VARIES FROM CAMPUS TO
CAMPUS- AND I'M CURIOUS AS TO
YOUR VIEWS ON THE ROLE THAT-
ACADEMIC COUNSELING. AFFECTED
MISS OF ACADEMIC COUNSELING
PLAY. FOR PLAYS IN. THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE. OF THAT
WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO PUSH
FORWARD. I AT CSU ONE- AND TWO
WHETHER YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ACADEMIC COUNSELOR TO
STUDENT RATIO AT C. ISSUE- AND
WHAT YOU THINK WE CAN DO ABOUT
THAT. YEAH BUT TO BE MORE MONEY
IT'S ALWAYS MORE MONEY SIR. IN
THE INTERIM I ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IT'S EXCITING I'M ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT MY GRADUATION
INITIATIVE KICHI IS IN A PART
OF THAT THAT THE CORE PIECE OF
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS
NOT JUST MORE COURSES- BUT HIS
GUIDANCE. WHEN I TALKED ABOUT
THAT CITY CALLED BY CITY
COLLEGE PASSED. BACK BEFORE WE
HAD- ONLINE ENROLLMENT YOU
WOULD FILL OUT A FORM. AND YOU
WOULD GET THE CLASSES THAT YOU
FILLED OUT IN THE CSU WHEN
YOU'RE REGISTERING UNDER THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE WE'VE NOT
ONLY DONE TO THE BRICK AND
MORTAR. INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
WE'VE ALSO INCREASE OUR
TECHNOLOGY YOU GET YOUR GETTING
ONLINE. GUIDANCE BUT YOU KNOW
THE IDEA THAT EACH CAMPUS GETS
INCREASED GUIDANCE STAFF THE
BUT IT'S NEVER GOING TO BE
ENOUGH I'M SO WE HAVE TO KEEP
PUSHING OUR AVERAGE THE AVERAGE
STUDENT POPULATION AT MOST OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND FOLKS- SO WE CAN
CONTINUE NOT ONLY TO INCREASE
OUR TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY CHOICE. A
STUDENT IS MAKING THERE'S A
GUIDANCE POINT IN ROME AT
THERE'S A GUIDANCE POINT IF YOU
ARE ENROLLING IN A CLASS THAT'S
NOT GOING TO DO YOU. THE SECOND
SEND YOU THROUGH THAT THEY-
THROUGH THE METICULOUS IN
PROCESS IT'LL IT'LL POP UP YOUR
ALSO ASKED TO PHYSICALLY SIT
DOWN WITH A HUMAN BEING BUT I
WOULD AGREE. WE NEED MORE
HUMANS. AT EVERY STAGE X.
SPECIALLY WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE.
ARE HAVING THE MOST TROUBLE NOT
JUST IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
SEMESTER BUT THE PRESIDENT SET
IN THE BEAUTIFUL PART ABOUT
BEING A TRUSTEE YOU GET TO GO
TO-THE CAMPUSES AND HANG OUT
WITH STUDENTS AND TALK TO STAFF
AND NOT JUST THE PRESIDEN'S
BUT- EVERY PRESIDENT THAT I'VE
TALKED TO AND WORKED WITH-
THEY'RE CONVINCED THAT THEIR
ROLE IS NOT ONLY TO KEEP. THE
INSTITUTION OF FLOAT BUT TO
MAKE SURE BEFORE THAT YOUNG
PERSON JUMPS OFF THE
EDUCATIONAL CLIFF THAT WE
GRABBED HIM BACK. IT'S AN
ONGOING ISSUE FOR THE
GRADUATION ISSUE OF APPROACHES.
AGAIN THE CORE OF THE PROBLEM
OF STUDENTS OF THE ATTRITION
BUT MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
SOME SUPPORT THERE HOPEFULLY
THE SYSTEM AS METRICS AND I
DON'T MEAN IT I DON'T MEAN JUST
HOW LONG IT TAKES A STUDENT TO
GET IN TO SEE AN ACADEMIC
COUNSELORS MIDDLE OF CANCERS OR
ENTER A DIFFERENT STORY. NOT
ANY BETTER BUT HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO GET INTO CITY SEE AN
ACADEMIC COUNSELOR AND SOME
STUDENT ASSESSMENT THE
CUSTOMER'S ASSESSMENT ON HOW
EFFECTIVE THE COUNSELING WAS AT
THE TIME BECAUSE MY PERCEPTION.
REMEMBER I AM SOLD THE ONE I
REGISTERED FOR CLASSES YOU
STOOD IN A LINE AND THEY HANDED
YOU A COMPUTER PUNCH CARD AND
WHEN THEY RAN OUT OF CARDS YOU
DIDN'T GET INTO THE CLASS THINK
IT WAS LIKE THAT IN NINETY
EIGHT SERVICE OUT TO OREGON.
BUT IF THERE'S A MISTAKE MADE
IN THE COUNT. THE STUDENT CAN'T
GET TO SEE THE COUNSELOR WITH
HIS COUNSELOR MAKES A MISTAKE-BECAUSE OF LACK OF TRAINING OR
EXPERIENCE. THAN MY PERCEPTION
IS THAT SETS COULD SET THE
STUDENT BACK ONE TWO THREE FOUR
SEMESTERS. IN TERMS OF MOVING
DOWN TOWARD THE GRADUATION
FINISH LINE AND SO. IT'S
INCUMBENT. FALLING BOND THE
INSTITUTION TO GIVE US THE DATA
TO ASSESS THE BUDGET REQUESTS
AND IT'S INCUMBENT ON THE
LEGISLATURE THAN. TO PROPERLY
FUND THE ACADEMIC COUNSELING
COMPONENT OF THE C. ISSUE AND
ALSO THE UC BUDGET SO THAT YOU
THE INSTITUTION HAS THE
COUNSELORS THE STUDENTS HAVE
THE COUNSELORS. NECESSARY TO
GET THROUGH THE PROCESS
SUFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
FIRST TIME EVERY TIME AND SO
I'D ASK YOU TO TAKE  LOOK AT
THAT AS WELL ABSOLUTELY AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SERVICE OF FORWARD TO MOVING
YOUR CONFIRMATION AS WELL THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR OFF. SO
LET ME- MOVED TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND ASK- THOSE WERE HERE
IN SUPPORT. TO PLEASE COME UP
ON A GIVE ME YOUR NAME YOU'RE
WHO YOU REPRESENT AND YOUR
COMMENTS WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON WHEN IS THAT IS MY
VALLEY KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
TRUSTEE SIGN SIMON AND WANT TO
MISPRONOUNCE- SHE BRINGS AN
EQUITY LANDS INTELLIGENCE AND
COMPASSION. AND IT WILL BE AN
ASSET TO NOT ONLY THE
UNIVERSITY BUT ALSO ALL THE
STUDENTS AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HI WELCOME HELLO
COLONEL AND THEN WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY I'M JUST HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF- TRUSTEE
SIMON THREE POINT ME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY PUT
A TRUSTEES. ESPECIALLY MISS
SIMON HAS DEMONSTRATED A FOCUS
ON RACIAL EQUITY ESPECIALLY AS
A BOY TAKES AN ADMISSIONS
POLICY THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO IMPACT THOUSANDS OF LATIN
XBOX STUDENTS. A MISS SIMON HAS
BEEN VERY ACCESSIBLE TO
STAKEHOLDERS COMMUNITY POP
PARTNERS AND THE STUDENTS WHO
SHE REPRESENTS AND HER SERVICE.
HE FURTHER PROVIDES A VALUABLE
PERSPECTIVE AND REPRESENTATION
TO THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES WHICH
IS STILL COMPRISES A PUBLIC
APPOINTEES THAT ARE. 60% WHITE
A 5053% MALE. YET REPRESENT THE
STUDENT BODY THAT IS FIFTY SIX
POINT 7% FEMALE AND 77% NON
WHITE. MISS SIMON IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR STATES
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATION AND
HAS PUT THE SUCCESS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF HER DECISION
MAKING ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HI I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JESSICA BARLOW THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. OF THE NOMINATION THE
APPOINTMENT. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE CSU SYSTEM IS THE LARGEST
AB PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY- AS YOU KNOW-
CHAIRWOMAN AND SPEAKER- AND AS
YOU KNOW. MISS SAM AND AS I
KNOW. THE PATH OUT OF POVERTY
FOR SO MANY CALIFORNIANS IS
PAVED WITH. EDUCATION. FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND CHILDREN BORN
INTO POVERTY. THEIR CHANCES OF
GETTING A POVERTY ARE VERY
SMALL. EDUCATION WILL BE A BIG
PART OF THAT IF THEY MAKE IT. I
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THIS
PERSONALLY- I KNOW ALSO THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO GO
THROUGH AN EDUCATION WITH
CHILDREN. A THIRD OF OUR
POPULATION AND OUR CS USE OUR
REGION WHERE STUDENTS AND MANY
OF THEM ARE STUDENTS WITH
CHILDREN WHEN A CHILD SEES A
PARENT GO THROUGH THEIR
EDUCATION THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
AND GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY- AND
CALIFORNIA IN GENERAL HAS
SUPPORTED EDUCATION AS A PATH
OUT OF POVERTY YOU KNOW THIS
VISION YOU'RE WORKING HARD TO
END HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS
WITHIN OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
AND I CAN THINK OF NOBODY ELSE.
NOBODY BETTER TO LEAD THIS
WORK- OF EQUITY- FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS- THAN THE PERSON
YOU HAVE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY
AND I'M SO IT'S THROUGH THE
ETHNICALLY SUPPORT HER
NOMINATION CONGRATULATIONS. Q.
HI WELCOME HI MY NAME'S
JENNIFER EGAN I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND OR SO FACULTY MEMBERS-
THAT WE REPRESENT AT THE CSU A
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE DEEP
ASSIGNMENTS REAPPOINTMENT. THE
DIVA SIMON HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
VERY FEW INDEPENDENT VOICES ON
THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES HE'S
CONSISTENTLY VOTED AGAINST
RAISING STUDENT FEES AND SPOKEN
THROUGH A SOCIAL JUSTICE LANDS
ON ISSUES SUCH AS THE PROPOSED
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENT. THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE AND THE HOUSING AND
FOOD AND SECURITY OF OUR
STUDENTS AMONG OTHER ISSUES. A
TRUSTEE SIMON IS CONNECTED TO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS COME
FROM MUCH MORE CLOSELY THAN
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE BOARD AND
IT SHOWS IN HER ACTIONS AND I
JUST WANNA TELL A VERY BRIEF
STORY ABOUT- HER AT THE WAY SHE
IS AT THE BOARD AND THE OF HER
PERFORMANCE AS A TRUSTEE. IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO THANK
TRUSTEE SIMON FOR THE HUMANITY
AND COMPASSION THAT SHE SHOWED
TO CHARMAINE LAWSON WHO IS THE
MOTHER OF DAVID JOSIAH LAWSON A
STUDENT AT HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY WHO WAS MURDERED
NEAR THE CAMPUS. CFA SUPPORTED
MISS LAWSON IN HER ATTEMPT TO
SEEK JUSTICE FOR HER SON AS
WELL AS SUPPORTING THE STUDENTS
WHO SPOKE OUT AGAINST
RACIALIZED VIOLENCE ON OUR
CAMPUSES WHICH INCLUDED FEAR OF
THE POLICE. WHILE THE OTHER
TRUSTEES IN THE ROOM AT FRANKLY
SAT THERE PRETTY MOTIONLESS AND
PRETTY PASSIONLESS AS MS LAWSON
EXPRESSED HER PAIN AND PLEADED
FOR HELP TRUSTEE SIMON
RESPONDED BY COMING TO HER
PUTTING HER ARM AROUND HER AND
HAVING A REAL CONVERSATION. NO
ONE ELSE DID THAT IN THE MOMENT
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY BUT THAT
IS WHY I THINK A TRUSTY SIMON'S
PRESENCE ON THE BOARD IS SO
IMPORTANT SO I WOULD LIKE THE
COMMITTEE AND TRUSTEE SIMON. TO
KNOW THAT THE FACULTY AND THE
STUDENT ACTIVISTS WHO ARE
PRESENT AT THE BOARD AND SEE
YOU IN ACTION. APPRECIATE YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY ARE
SEEING NINE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH MADAM SECRETARY SENATORS
BATES. BATES AYE MONNING
MONNING AYE ROTH IRA ROTH I
WILL WRITE WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
IT'S UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS.
I TRY NEVER TO CRY IN PUBLIC
BUT THIS WORK IS SO IMPORTANT
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR TO GRADUATIONS AND- WE
WILL. ADJOURN INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION AND. START IS AS THE
ROOM IS CLEARED